it's september which means pumpkin spice
lattes an influx of green day memes and
a whole bunch of new games are coming to
playstation plus regardless of which
subscription plan you're on there are
plenty of games to download stream and
enjoy here's what you can expect
first up are the new monthly games added
to playstation plus you get access to
these regardless of which ps plus plan
you have all you got to do is add them
to your library and they're yours as
long as your subscription is active your
first monthly game is need for speed
heat for playstation 4 which pitch you
against the police as you climb your way
up the ladder to become the best of the
best at street racing earn resources to
upgrade your cars by taking part in the
palm city speed runner showdown during
the day and take part in street races by
night to boost your reputation your next
monthly game is grand blue fantasy
versus for playstation 4. a fighting
game meets rpg adventure developed by
arc system works the team behind persona
4 arena and dragon ball fighterz expect
a fighting game that's easy to get a
grips with but tougher to master your
final monthly game for september is toem
for playstation 5. tome is a cozy game
where you help solve puzzles by taking
pictures the game is full of quirky
characters very chill music and detailed
environments to explore you can complete
it in one or two sittings and it's the
perfect game to play as these autumn
chills roll in you can add all these
games to your collections starting on
september 6th and you'll need to redeem
them by october 3rd
if you have the playstation plus extra
or premium plan you can access the game
catalog as well as the ubisoft plus
classics collection this month sees a
huge number of games being added to the
game catalogs so let's go through them
first up death loop for playstation 5.
this one's special for us here at
gamespot because not only did we give it
a rare 10 out of 10 but we also awarded
it our 2021 game of the year it's the
latest from arcane lion the developer
behind dishonored and it has possibly
the coolest premise for a game that
we've ever played you play as colt
vaughn an assassin caught in a groundhog
daytime loop who can only escape if he
kills eight marks in one loop add powers
different times of day and a
mind-bending puzzle to solve into the
mix and death loop is truly unlike
anything you've played before next up
are a couple from the ubisoft plus
classics collection assassins creed
origins and watch dogs 2 both for the
playstation 4. assassin's creed origins
is a fully open world adventure set in
ancient egypt taking us back to a key
moment in the series lore the founding
of the assassins brotherhood as bayek
and occasionally as his wife you seek
revenge for the death of your son and
fall in with the hidden ones basically
the brotherhood before they became the
brotherhood watch dogs 2 is an open
world hacking adventure set in the san
francisco bay area because let's face it
if you're gonna stick it to big tech
where else would you set your game other
than the heart of silicon valley the
main cast of watch dogs 2 is much
cheerier than popha's aiden pierce from
watch dogs 1 and the quirky gang band
together to form the hacking group
dedsec but that's not all from ubisoft
next up is rabbids invasion the
interactive tv show which as the title
suggests is an interactive tv show
featuring everyone's favorite little
weird rabbit things if you or some kids
in your life dig rabbids this game lets
you play a number of minigames as you
watch an episode of tv show at the same
time there's also raymond legends a
personal favorite legends is the sequel
to raymond origins the 2011 game that
took raymond back to his 2d roots
legends builds upon the fantastic
foundation set by origins by adding new
levels including some incredible ones
set to music as well as 3d boss fights
it's very fun to play alone or with
friends and finally from ubisoft is
scott pilgrim vs the world the game
complete edition a side-scrolling
beat-em-up based on the bryan lee
o'malley comic book series and the edgar
wright movie adaptation the game can be
tough but that only means you get to
listen to the incredible onomanoguchi
soundtrack for longer also added to the
game catalog this month is dragon ball
xenoverse 2 for the playstation 4.
another rpg fighting game mix that is
definitely one for dragon ball fans to
hit not only does the game allow you to
customize your own character and take
them on an adventure but you'll also
battle a bunch of infamous dragon ball
baddies from different timelines another
addition is spirit fairer farewell
edition for playstation 4. spirit fair
is a gorgeous game where you play as
stella a spirit pharah who helps spirits
pass over to the other side in the game
you'll meet a variety of characters
learn about their life and help them
complete their unfinished business
before you can send them on to the
afterlife there's also a management
aspect to the game as you can build your
ferry farm and craft items spiritfair is
a relaxing thought-provoking game that
will stick with you long after you've
put down the controller and if you're
feeling artsy how's about some chicory a
colorful tale where you play as a dog
with a magic paintbrush play alone or
with a friend in local co-op and solve
puzzles by adding color back into the
world whether you have a strict color
scheme in mind or you just want to draw
butts on everything the world is your
oyster and finally coming to game
catalog is monster energy supercross the
official video game 5 and alex kidd in
miracle world dx for playstation 4 and
ps5 become a supercross champion make
your own tricks play against your
friends in multiplayer in monster energy
supercross and relive an updated classic
in alice kidd all those games will be
joining the catalog on september 20th
a number of games from past playstation
generations are also joining the
classics catalog on september 20th to
access these games you'll need
playstation plus premium which is the
plan that also nets you game trials
first up is the sly collection the ps3
remasters of sly cooper and the this
raccoonis sly 2 band of thieves and sly
3 honor among thieves sly cooper thieves
in time also joins the catalog and in
this one you travel through time to meet
and play as some of sly's ancestors to
save the family's legacy from fading
finally there's bentley's hack pack a
mini game collection from thieves in
time the games will all be available to
stream on september 20th also coming to
the classics catalog is toy story 3 for
the psp a platformer that loosely
follows the events of the movie it's a
psp game but it's seen a little bit of a
facelift with this release giving the
title up rendering custom video filters
rewind and the ability to quick save
your progress another psp title coming
to the classics catalog is kingdom of
paradise a role-playing game with some
interesting ideas in the game you'll
collect new moves in the world and mix
and match them to create your own form
of martial arts the final game coming to
playstation plus catalog this month is
2000's stealth action game siphon filter
2. play as both gabe logan and leon zing
as you attempt to figure out the secret
of the mysterious agency and their
relationship to the siphon filter virus
syphon filter 2 also features custom
video filters up rendering quick save
and rewind
so there you have it a whole load of
games coming to playstation plus this
month regardless of which plan you're on
there is bound to be something to enjoy
so let us know in the comments below
which game you'll be digging into this
month we'll be back next month with more
games on playstation plus but we also
cover the latest titles dropping on game
pass too so if you're subscribed to that
make sure you give it a watch as well
i'm on twitter at devante chisholm i'll
catch you next time